it's fun to do these sort of crafty
creative projects during the holidays
too because it's a nice way to slow down
take a minute to do a fun activity
together reconnect i find this very
relaxing
[Music]
hi i'm erin i'm a creator of buzzfeed
and i am so excited for the holidays
this year i just had a new baby our
family is growing so we have so many
traditions and fun things to do today
i'm going to create a custom garland for
our mantelpiece to show off our
personalized stockings from ebay
so this is a super cute personalized
ornament for chloe the great thing is
ebay has an assortment of personalized
gifts so you can get things that are
really special to each person in your
family baby chloe's first christmas and
she loves to dance for my older daughter
charlotte we have this personalized
unicorn if it has rainbows sparkle
glitter it's for her so this is perfect
charlotte gets this really cute
personalized reindeer stocking she just
learned how to recognize her name she
could read and spell her name so being
able to see this on a stocking will make
her super happy my husband allen gets a
pizza ornament my husband is a food
writer this one is totally for him we
love to travel it is something that we
did a lot together before we had our
beautiful girls so hopefully we'll get
back to it soon
i'm making a custom mantle display to
really enhance the new ebay personalized
stockings that i got the first thing i
like to do is add the ornaments and the
easiest way to add ornaments to a
garland is with green pipe cleaners they
blend right into the rest of the
greenery you thread it through
and make a little loop like this
and then you use these ends
to attach it to your garland
i like to start with my favorite colors
and then make a pattern sort of around
that so i'm adding the pinks and the
blues first
it's okay if you leave the ends of your
pipe cleaners out for now we can use
them to attach more ornaments in a
minute or we'll just snip them before
we're done
next i'm going to add some pine cones i
do it the exact same way with the pipe
cleaner you just put it through
the little leaves like this and twist
you can also use hot glue but i tend to
like using the pipe cleaners because i
feel like it's more secure
and this way you can kind of add it to
fill out any areas that are a little
sparse so if you have a store-bought
garland like this it's an easy way to
really make it look fluffy and pat it
out make it look more expensive
[Music]
this is also a great activity if you
want to have your kids collect pine
cones if they fall on the ground where
you live
they love helping you find these
so we're going to add acrylic paint to
the edges of the pinecones just to
decorate them a little bit i like to do
just the tips that way it's sort of a
whisper of color it lets you keep that
natural element this very classic
pinecone evergreen garland plus a pop of
color is definitely my style
this looks so cute i'm going to let the
pine cones dry and then i'm going to add
a few more things one final way that i'm
going to personalize this garland is by
adding really cute pictures of our
family i love decor that sort of
delights you as you get closer and look
at all the little details and i think
personalizing it with our own photos
will be so special
so i have these little photos printed
out and little teeny tiny clothes pins
and i'm just going to go in and add them
where i need to sort of fill out the
garland a bit
the last thing i'm going to do is trim
the pipe cleaners and add a couple extra
ornaments to make it extra personal
nice this is looking super cute i am so
happy with how this garland turned out i
think my family will love it i can't
wait to see their faces when chloe
charlotte and alan see the mantle see
the garland and the personalized
stockings and i have an ornament to put
in each one it's so nice to have these
personal touches during the holidays
because it really is all about family
and seeing their faces seeing the things
that they love brought to life and
personalized stockings ornaments all of
these decorations just makes it that
much more meaningful
ebay is your shopping destination for
personalized gifts this holiday season
be sure to check out ebay for a variety
of gifts and decor that you can
personalize this holiday season